Well,
and I know a politician, in addition to the leader of
the majority of the Senate, Harry Reid dies at the
age of 82, how are you greetings? Cristian
Cásseres, laughing, died Tuesday
night surrounded by his relatives. Many
politicians at the national and local level
remember laughing like a fighter of
intense passion for the state of nevada
the flags will be at half mast in his
memory there is also a great loss in
the world of football
hall of fame coach
and broadcaster jon gnarr in died at
85 he led the raiders  from oakland
you are then to his first
super bowl title in 1977 they lit the
torch located in the ali and
jane stadium in his memory in addition to dedicating a
few words to him and I tell you that the
singer katy perry will begin to
promote his residence within the
resort world from
wednesday night there you can officially
attend perry play land and this ends
march 19th and we close with a look at the
temperatures we will have  a sunny day
although the cold will feel throughout
the day for the night there is a slight
possibility of rain remember to wrap up
and protect yourself from the cold
if you plan to receive the new year outside
enjoying the fireworks
I am cristian cásseres with your brief
informative of news now in  Spanish good
day